and they need to make the whole campaign
about those dirty rotten mean old
republicans so
they haven't gotten anything good on
trump lately they're trying to accuse
him of
mail fraud or some i don't know what
they're trying to accuse him of so now
they're going after
their favorite the king of conservative
talk radio and conservative commentary
rush limbaugh rush limbaugh
on the air read some criticisms for
kamala harris
the left is saying that rush called
kamala harris
a hoe that's the exact wording
now as as always they've been doing this
for decades
the left attacks rush limbaugh for
things that he
allegedly said and then they never
listened to the full context
so if they did they would find out that
he didn't actually say what they're
saying he said
take a listen for yourself the nba
has fired a freelance photographer
because he insulted kamala harris his
name is bill
baptiste maybe pronounces it baptist i
don't know there's no e on the end of it
he's a freelance photographer he's been
working for the nba
inside its bubble at the disney world
complex in orlando as the nba
goes through its supposed season here
he's an independent contractor had the
deal terminated by the league
after he posted a
sexist facebook post referencing
kamala harris
he posted an image that read joe
and the ho hoe
now what do you think that's about what
do you think that's about so he's
he's just reading the story of what
the guy who then got fired said about
kamala here so
it is newsworthy you got this guy who
gets fired for saying this thing and
he's just repeating what the guy said
that is not rush limbaugh calling
kamala harris a hoe but i'd like to go
further than that
what if he did call her a ho or whatever
you know whatever use whatever word you
want what if he did do that
isn't that what the left has been
telling us is true of women for decades
now and isn't
left telling us that that's empowering
remember we played that song by cardi b
who now you know is being elevated to
the point that she's she's going on and
doing interviews with joe biden
we play that song wap wap which is the
most
vulgar disgusting song i've ever heard
and the thesis of which is
all women are prostitutes there's some
[ __ ] in this house so cardi b can say
it but rush limbaugh can't say it
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]